YUFEI ZHAO: OK, we are
still on our journey
to proving Freiman theorem.
Right?
So we've been
looking at some tools
for analyzing sets
of small doubling.
And last time, we showed
the following result,
that if a has small doubling,
then there exists a prime.
It's not too much
bigger than a, such
that a big subset of a, of
at least 1/8 proportion,
a big subset of a is Freiman
8-isomorphic to a subset
of this small cyclic group.
So last time, we developed this
tool called of modeling lemma,
so Ruzsa's modeling
lemma that allows
us to pass from a set of small
doubling, which could have
elements very spread
out in the integers,
to something that is much more
compact, a much tighter set.
That's a subset, a
positive proportionate
subset of a small cyclic group.
And remember, the last time we
defined this notion of Freiman
8-isomorphic, Freiman
isomorphism, in this case,
it just means that it preserves
partially additive structure.
It preserves additive
structure when
you look at most 8-wise sums.
All right.
Well, this is where
we left off last time.
If you start with
small doubling,
then I can model a big
portion of this set
by a large fraction of
a small cyclic group.
All right.
So now, we're in
the setting where
we are looking at some space,
a cyclic group, for instance.
And now, we have
positive proportion,
a constant proportion
subset of that group.
And we would like to extract
some additional additive
structure from this large set.
And that should
remind you of things
we've discussed when we
talked about Roth's theorem.
Right?
So Roth's theorem
also had this form.
If you start with Z mod n or
in the finite field setting,
and you have a constant
proportion of the space,
then you must find a three-term
arithmetic progression.
In fact, you must
find many three-APs.
So we're going to do something
very similar, at least
in spirit, here.
We're starting from this large
proportion of some space.
We're going to extract a very
large additive structure, just
from the size alone.
So let me begin by motivating
it with a question.
And we're going to start,
as we've done in the past,
with a finite field model, where
things are much easier to state
and to analyze.
The question is, suppose
you have a set a, which
is a subset of f2 to the m.
And a is an alpha proportion
of the space where you think
of alpha as some constant.
Question is, OK,
suppose this is true.
And must it be the case
that a plus a the subset--
all right, so a itself,
just because it's
a large proportion of the space.
So just because it's
the 1% of the space,
doesn't mean that it contains
any large structures.
It doesn't contain necessarily
any large sub-spaces,
because it could be a more
random subset of f to the m.
But there's a general principle
in additive combinatorics
or even analysis where if
you start with a set that
is quite large, and it might be
a bit rough, a is a bit rough,
it's all over the place.
If you add a to itself,
it smooths out the set.
So a plus a is much
smoother than a.
And the question is, must A
plus A contain a large subspace?
And here, by "large,"
I mean the following.
Because we're looking
at constant proportions
of the entire
space, by "large," I
would also want a constant
proportion of the entire space.
So does there
exist some subspace
of bounded codimension?
So if alpha is a
constant, I want
a bounded codimensional subspace
that lives inside A plus A.
It turns out the answer is no.
So there exists sets that, even
though there are very large
and you add it to
itself, it still
doesn't have large subspaces.
So let me give you an example.
And this construction
is called a nivo set.
So let's take A sub n to be the
set of points in F2 to the n
who's Hamming weight--
so Hamming weight here
is just the number
of 1's or it's a number
of non-zero elements--
number of 1's in
x or, in general,
the number of non-zero
elements among the coordinates
of x, so the number of
non-zero coordinates.
And I want the Hamming weight
to be less than this quantity
here.
So visually, what
this looks like is
I'm thinking of the
Hamming cube placed
so that the all-zero
vector is here,
the all-ones vector is up there.
And then it's sorted
by Hamming weight.
So this is called
a Boolean lattice.
And I'm looking at
all the elements, A,
which are within a Hamming
ball of the 0 vector.
So this is the set.
It's not too hard to
calculate the size of the set,
because I'm taking everything
with Hamming weight
less than this quantity over
here by central limit theorem.
The number of elements
in the set is of the form
a constant fraction
of the entire space,
where alpha is some
constant if c is a constant.
So it has the desired size.
But also, A added
to itself consists
of points in the Boolean
cube whose Hamming weight
is at most n minus c root n.
And I claim that
this sumset does not
contain any subspace of
dimension larger than n minus c
root n.
So this is the final claim.
It's something that's, again,
one of these linear algebraic
exercises that we've actually
seen earlier when we discussed
the proof of a cap set, right,
so the polynomial method
proof of cap set.
If you have a
subspace of dimension
greater than some
quantity, then you
should be able to find a
vector in that subspace whose
support has size at
least the dimension.
OK.
So you see, in
particular, we do not
have any bounded codimensional
subspaces in this A plus A.
So even though the
philosophy is roughly right
that if you start with a set
A and you add it to itself,
it smooths out
the set, it should
contain-- we expect it to
contain some large structure.
That's not quite true.
But what turns out to be true,
and this is the first result
that I will show today,
is that if you add A
to itself a few more
times, that, indeed,
you can get large subspaces.
And this is an important step
in a proof of Freiman's theorem.
And this step is known
as Bogolyubov's lemma.
So Bogolyubov's lemma, in
the case of F2 to the n,
says that if you
have a subset A of F2
to the n of fraction alpha of
the space, then 2A minus 2A
contains a bounded codimensional
subspace, so a very large
subspace.
so 2A minus 2A contains
a subspace of codimension
less than 1 over alpha squared.
Here, I write 2A minus 2A
even though we're in F2.
So this is the same as 4A.
But in general-- and you'll
see later on when we do it
in integers--
2A minus 2A is the right
expression to look at.
So 2A minus 2A, something
that works in every group.
But for F2 to the n,
it's the same as 4A.
So the main philosophy here
is that adding is smoothing.
You start with a large
subset of F2 to the n.
It's large.
Does it contain
large structures?
Not necessarily.
But you add it to itself, and
it smooths out the picture.
So it has a rough spot.
It smooths it out.
And if you keep
adding A to itself,
it smooths it out even further.
You add it to
itself enough times,
and then it will contain
a large structure
and just from the
size of A alone.
And there is a very
similar idea, which
comes up all over the
place in analysis,
is that convolutions
are smoothing.
So you start with some function
that might be very rough.
If you convolve it
with itself and if you
do it many more times,
you get something
that is much smoother.
And in fact, adding
and convolutions
are almost the same things.
And I'll explain
that in a second.
So this is an important idea
to take away from all of this.
So when we do these free
analytic calculations--
so there will be some free
the first time you see
them, they might just
seem like calculations.
So you push the symbols around,
and you get some inequalities.
You get some answers.
But that's no way to
learn the subject.
So you need to
figure out, what is
the intuition behind each step?
Because when you need
to work on it yourself,
you're not just guessing the
right symbols to put down.
You have to understand
the intuition, like why,
intuitively, each inequality
should be expected to hold?
And this is an important
idea that adding is smoothing
and convolution is smoothing.
All right.
So let me remind you
about convolutions.
So recall, in a
general abelian group,
if I have two functions,
f and g, on the group--
so complex value functions--
then the convolution
is given by the
following formula.
So that's the convolution.
And it behaves very
well with respect
to the Fourier transform.
The Fourier transform
turns convolutions
into multiplications.
So this means, point
wise, I have that.
Convolutions also relate to
some sets, because if I--
and this is the
interpretation of convolutions
that I want you to keep
in mind for the purpose
of additive combinatorics.
If you have two
sets, A and B, then
look at the convolution
of their indicators.
It has an interpretation.
So if you read out
what this value says,
then what this comes
out to is 1 divided
by the size of the group over
the number of pairs in A and B
such that their sum is x.
So up to normalization,
convolution records
some sets with multiplicities.
So the convolution
tells you how many ways
are there to express x in
terms of a sum of one element
from A and another
element from B.
And in particular,
this function here
is supported on the
sumset A plus B.
So this is the way that
convolutions and sumsets
are intimately
related to each other.
So that's proof
Bogolyubov's lemma.
We're going to be looking at
this sumset, which is related
to the following convolution.
So let f be this convolution
of indicators, AA minus A minus
A. Of course, in
F2 to the n, you
don't need to worry
about the minus signs.
But I'll keep them there
for future reference.
Here, by what we said
earlier, the support of f
is 2A minus 2A.
It's not too hard to evaluate
the Fourier transform of f,
because Fourier transform plays
very well with convolutions.
So in this case, it is the
Fourier transform of A squared,
Fourier transform
of minus A squared.
The Fourier transform of minus
A, if you look at the formula,
is the conjugate.
It's a complex conjugate of
the Fourier transform of A.
So again, in F2 to the n,
they're actually the same.
But in general, it's
the complex conjugate.
So we always have
this formula here.
So we always have that.
So by the Fourier
inversion formula,
we can write f in terms
of its Fourier transform.
Here, I'm using that.
We're now using that.
We're in F2, so that's
what the inverse Fourier
transform looks like.
And so we have the
following formula
for the value of f in terms
of the Fourier transform
of the original set.
OK.
We want to show that f, whose
support is the 2A minus 2A
we're interested in--
we want to show the
support of f contains
a large subspace, a small,
codimensional subspace.
So observe that if f has
positive value, then--
if f of x is positive,
then x lies in its support.
So we just want to
find a large subspace
on which f is positive.
But we can choose our
subspace by looking
at Fourier coefficients
according to their size.
So what we can do is let R
be the set of, essentially,
Fourier characters whose
corresponding value
in the Fourier
transform is large.
So it's at least
alpha to the 3/2.
And that value
will come up later.
So let's look at
this R. And what
we're going to do is
we're going to look
at the orthogonal
complement of R
and show that f is positive on
the orthogonal complement of R.
First, R is not too large.
The size of R is, I claim,
less than 1 over alpha squared.
Why's that?
So this is an important
trick that we've
seen a few times before.
The number of large Fourier
coefficients cannot be too
large, because they're Parseval,
which tells us that the sum
of the squares of the Fourier
coefficients is equal to the L2
norm of the original
function, which, in this case,
is just the density
of A. So that's alpha.
So just looking at that, the
number of large terms cannot be
too many.
OK.
So we have this small set, R,
on which f has large Fourier
transform values.
Now, let's look at f of x.
So let's look at f of x.
We want to find out, when
can we control f of x
to make sure it is positive?
Well, for the values of r--
little r-- not in big R or
0, we see that the Fourier
transform--
we would like to upper bound
this quantity here so that this
is negligible.
This is a small term.
Again, this is a
computation that we've
seen several times
earlier in this course.
All of these terms are small.
So I want to show that
the whole sum is small.
I don't want to bound each term
individually and then sum up
all the possible contributions.
That will be too big.
But we've seen this trick
before where we just take out
some subset of the factors.
So in particular, I'll
take out two of the factors
and get alpha cubed upper bound
plus the remaining factors.
And once again, use Parseval
on this very last sum,
keeping in mind that
I'm throwing away
some of the r's, including 0.
So it will be a
strict inequality.
OK.
Yeah.
So this step should be
reminiscent of very similar
computations that we did in
the proof of Roth's theorem.
So if x lies in the orthogonal
complement of uppercase R, then
f of x--
well, let's evaluate f of x from
the Fourier inversion formula.
We have this.
So I can now split the sum as
the 0-th term, the large terms.
Now, you see, for
the large terms,
because we're in the
orthogonal complement of A,
I can make sure that they all
come with a positive sign.
And finally, the small terms.
And you see that the main
term is alpha to the 4.
This term is always
non-negative.
And the error terms,
the small terms,
are strictly less than alpha
to the 4th in magnitude.
So as a result, this
whole sum is positive.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: These 1's are
also 1 sub A's, right?
YUFEI ZHAO: Thank you.
The 1's are 1 sub A's.
Yeah.
So this is the very
similar philosophy
to when we proved
Roth's theorem.
We look at a sum like this,
so some trigonometric series,
some Fourier series.
And we decompose it
into several terms
based on how large their
Fourier coefficients are.
We can control the small ones
using what essentially amounts
to a counting lemma and show
that the small ones cannot ever
annihilate the large,
dominant terms.
So as a result, f
of x is positive
on the orthogonal
complement of R.
So thus R lies in
the support of f,
which is equal to 2A minus 2A.
And furthermore, the
codimension of R is at most--
so it could be some
linear dependencies--
is at most the size of R,
which is strictly less than 1
over alpha squared.
And that proves
Bogolyubov's lemma.
So if you have a large
subset of F2 to the n,
you add it to
itself enough times
so that it's a
smoothing operation.
And then eventually, you
must find a large structure.
And we only start by
assuming the size of it.
If it's just large
enough, then we
can find a large structure
within this iterated sumset.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't R in
support of R [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry, come again?
AUDIENCE: You got that the
orthogonal complement of R--
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry.
The orthogonal complement
of R is in the support.
Yeah.
So R lives in the
character space.
OK, great.
So this is the proof
of Bogolyubov's lemma
in the finite field
setting, working
in F2 to the n, which is fine.
It's a useful setting as a
playground for us to work in.
But ultimately, we
want to understand
what happens in the integers.
So if you look at where
we left off last time,
we started in the
cyclic group, Z mod n.
So we would like to know how
to formulate a similar result
but in the cyclic group where
there are no more subspaces.
We encountered a
similar situation,
although we didn't
go into it, when
we discussed Roth's theorem.
In the first proof
of Roth's theorem
that we showed, in the
first Fourier analytic proof
in the finite field
setting, the proof
won by restricting to
subspaces, to hyperplanes.
And then we keep on iterating
by restricting to hyperplanes.
So you can stay in subspaces.
And the finite field setting
has lots of subspaces.
And we said that to get that
proof to work in the integers,
we had to do
something different.
And we did something by
restricting to intervals.
But I also mentioned
that, somehow, that's
not the natural
analog of subspaces.
The natural analog of subspaces
is something called a Bohr set.
And so I want to explore
this idea further now.
So the natural analog
of subspaces in Z mod n
are these objects
called Bohr sets.
And they're defined as follows.
So suppose you are given
some R, a subset of Z mod n.
We define a Bohr set,
denoted like this, so
Bohr of R and epsilon, to
be the subset of Z mod n,
so including elements
x, such that rx
is pretty close to
a multiple of n.
So here, we're looking
at the R mod Z norm.
So this is the distance to
the closest integer such
that this fraction is very close
to an integer for all little r
and big R. You see, this
is the analog of subspaces,
because in the finite field
setting, the finite field
vector space, even if I
set epsilon to equal to 0
and turn this into
an inner product,
then Bohr sets are exactly
subspaces-- namely,
the orthogonal
complement of the set R.
But now we're in the integers,
where you don't have exact 0.
But I just want that quantity,
that norm, to be small enough.
So let me give you some names.
So given the Bohr set,
which, technically
speaking, is more
than just the set
itself but also includes the
information of R and epsilon--
so it's the entire data
written on the board--
we call the size of the R
the dimension of the Bohr set
and epsilon, the width.
Bogolyubov's lemma for Z mod n
now takes the following form.
If you start with a subset A of
Z mod n, and all I need to know
is that A is a constant
fraction of the cyclic group,
then the iterated
sumset 2A minus 2A
contains some Bohr
set Bohr R of 1/4
with the size of R less
than 1 over alpha squared.
So earlier, we said that if
you have a large subset of F2
to the n, then 2A minus 2A
contains a large subspace.
And now we say that
if A is a large subset
of the cyclic group,
then 2A minus 2A
contains a large Bohr
set of small dimension.
And so this terminology
may be slightly confusing.
The dimension corresponds
to codimension previously.
So if you do this
translation, this dimension--
I mean, if R were a set
of independent vectors
and you have 2 to
the n, then that'll
be the codimension of the
corresponding subspace.
But this is the terminology
that we're stuck with.
OK.
Any questions about
the statement?
You see, even the bounds are
exactly the same, 1 over alpha
squared.
And I mean, the
proof is going to be
pretty much exactly
the same once you
make the correct
notational modifications.
So we're going to do that.
So I'm going to write on
top of this earlier proof
and show you what are the
notational modifications so
that you can get exactly
the same result here
but with Bohr sets
instead of a subspace.
The thing to keep in mind
is that we have a somewhat
different Fourier transform.
So let me now use
different colored chalk.
So the Fourier transform of
a function f from Z mod n,
so a complex value,
is a function
also on Z mod n defined by f
hat of r equal to expectation
over x in Z mod n of
f of x times omega
to the minus rx, where omega
is a primitive n root of unity.
And you also had the
Fourier inversion formula.
It's what you expect.
I won't bother writing it down.
So we go back to the proof.
And pretty much everything
will read exactly the same.
So f is still the same f.
And the Fourier transform
has the same property.
So all of these nice properties
of the Fourier transform hold.
For inversion, it's
basically the same
except that the formula
is slightly different.
So instead of minus
1 to the r dot
x, what we have now
is omega to the rx.
So here, we have
omega to the rx.
OK.
Great.
The next part is the
same, where we define r.
So now we define r to consist
of elements of z mod n, whose
Fourier transform is large.
I can take out 0.
OK.
This part is still the same.
It's the same calculation.
Now, it's the very
last part that needs
to be just slightly changed.
Where does the 1/4 come in?
So where does this come in?
So observe that if x is in
the Bohr set with width 1/4,
then rx divided by n is--
OK, so by definition,
all of these fractions
are within the
1/4 of an integer.
And if you think about what
happens on the unit circle,
if you are within
1/4 of the integer,
then that means the
corresponding place on the unit
circle is on the
left half circle.
So in particular, the cosine
of 2rx over n is non-negative.
So it has non-negative
real part.
So now we go back to
this part of the proof,
where we're applying Fourier
inversion formula to f of x.
So we had the Fourier
inversion formula up there.
But because f of x is real,
it's really the cosine
that should come in play.
It should be a cosine.
And now, for the next step,
we have no negative sign here,
because this step--
OK, let me just cross
out this step over there.
All of these terms,
the terms that
correspond to
little r and big R,
they have non-negative
contribution.
Whatever the contributions
here, it's non-negative.
So I cross out this term.
All I'm left with
is the main term,
corresponding to the
density, and the error term,
so to speak, the minor terms,
which is less than alpha
to the 4th in absolute value.
OK.
So it's positive.
So basically the same proof.
Once you make the
appropriate modifications,
it's the same proof in Z mod n.
OK, great.
So this concludes our discussion
of Bogolyubov's lemma.
So it says that--
OK, so continuing
our previous thread,
we start with a subset of z
mod n of constant proportion.
Then 2A minus 2A necessarily
contains a large Bohr set.
And the next thing I want to do
is to start with this Bohr set.
So that's the definition
of a Bohr set.
But what does it look like?
So it's a bit hard to imagine.
So what does it look like?
In the finite field setting,
we know it's a subspace.
But in the Z mod n
setting, right now, it's
just some subset of Z mod n.
OK, so in the next
step, we want to extract
some geometric structure
from this Bohr set.
So we're going to
show that this Bohr
set will contain a large,
generalized arithmetic
progression.
So you asked something
earlier about--
something seems a bit fishy
about the general strategy.
Seems like our
goal for proving--
we want to prove
Freiman's theorem, which
says that the
conclusion is that A
is contained in some GAP,
some fairly compact additive
structure.
And we're already
losing quite a bit.
So we pass down
to 1/8 of A. So it
seems like even if
you contain the rest,
even if you can contain this
fraction, this large fraction
of A, what are you going
to do about the rest of A?
That's an unanswered question.
A second unanswered
question-- so right now,
what I've told you,
the strategy is
we're going to find a large
GAP inside 2A minus 2A,
which is not quite the
thing that we want to do.
We want to contain
A in a small GAP.
But at least it's
some progress, right?
It's some progress to
find some structure.
I mean, the name of
the game is to try
to find additive structure.
So in the theme of
this whole semester
course is trying to understand
the dichotomy between structure
and pseudorandomness.
And when you have structure,
let's use that structure.
See if you can boost
that structure.
So there will be an
additional argument, which
I will show you at the
beginning of next lecture
at the conclusion of the proof
of Freiman's theorem, which
will allow you to start with the
structure on a small part of A,
but not too small-- it's
a constant fraction of A--
and pass it up to
the whole of A.
And we've actually
already seen a tool
that allows us to do that.
So I want to cover all
of A. So last time, we
did something called
the covering lemma,
Ruzsa covering
lemma, that tells us
that if you have some
nice control on A
and you can cover some
part of A very well,
then I can cover the
entirety of A very well.
So those tools
will come in hand.
I mean, so similar
to actually how we
proved Freiman's theorem in
groups with bounded exponent.
And so we're going
to use the covering
lemma to conclude the theorem.
But now I want to
get into the issue
of the geometry of numbers.
OK.
I want to tell you
some necessary tools
that we'll need to find a
large GAP inside 2A minus 2A.
Now, it will seem like
a bit of a digression,
but we'll come back into
additive combinatorics
in a bit.
So the geometry of numbers
concerns the study of lattices.
So it concerns the study of
lattices and convex bodies.
So this is a really important
area of mathematics, especially
about a century ago with
mathematicians like Minkowski
playing foundational
roles in the subject.
So number theorists were
very interested in trying
to understand how
lattices behave.
So I'll tell you some
very classical results
that we'll use for
proving Freiman's theorem.
So first, what is a lattice?
So let me give you the following
definition of a lattice in R
to the d.
It's a structure on a group,
if you will, as an integer
span of d independent vectors.
So I start with v1
through vd vectors
that are linearly independent.
And I look at
their integer span.
I think this is best
explained with a picture.
So if I have a bunch of--
so here, I'm drawing
a picture in R2.
And this picture extends
in all directions.
If I start with two vectors, v1
and v2, linearly independent,
and look at their integer
span, so that's a lattice.
So that's what a lattice is.
You can come up with all
sorts of fancy definitions,
like a discrete
subgroup of R to the n.
But this is what it is.
So just to emphasize this
definition for a bit--
and also, one more
definition that we'll need
is the determinant of a lattice.
So what's the
determinant of a lattice?
One way to define it is you
look at these v's, and you
construct a matrix with
the v's as columns.
And you evaluate the absolute
value of this determinant.
More visually, the determinant
of a lattice is also equal
to the volume of its
fundamental parallelepiped,
which is a
parallelepiped-- well,
in the two-dimensional
case, it's a parallelogram--
which is spanned by v1 and
v2 or these v's, although you
have more choices, right?
So you could have
chosen a different set
of generating vectors.
For example, you could have
chosen these two vectors,
and they also generate
the same lattice.
And that's also a
fundamental parallelepiped.
And they will have
the same volume.
You can make some wrong
choices, and then they
will not have the right volume.
So if you had chosen
these two, so this
is not a fundamental
parallelepiped.
Great.
So let me give
you some examples.
The simplest lattice is just
the integer lattice, Zd,
which has determinant 1.
If I'm in the
complex plane, which
is viewed as two-dimensional
real plane, then if I take,
let's say, omega being
the 3rd root of unity,
I have a triangular lattice.
And the fundamental
parallelepiped
of this lattice,
that's one example.
And you can evaluate
its determinant
as the area of
that parallelogram.
If I take two nonlinearly
independent vectors--
so for example, if
I'm in one dimension
and I look at the integer
span of 1 and root 2,
this is not a lattice.
Now, the next definition
will initially
be slightly confusing.
But I will explain
it through an example
or at least try to help you
visualize what's going on.
So if I give you a centrally
symmetric convex body--
"centrally symmetric" means
that k equals to minus k.
So centrally symmetric
convex body, OK.
So here, centrally
symmetric is x in k
if and only if minus x is in k.
And I'm in d dimensions.
Let me define the i-th
successive minimum
to be lambda i.
OK, so i-th successive minimum
of k with respect to lambda
to be the infimum of all
non-negative lambda such that
the dimension of the span of the
intersection of lambda k and--
well, little o lambda
k and the lattice--
has dimension at least i.
OK.
So let me explain.
I start with a lattice.
So I start with some lattice.
And I have some convex body.
So this is 0, let's say.
So I have some convex body,
a centrally symmetric convex
body like that.
I initially could
be bigger, as well,
but that's scale it so that
it's quite small initially.
And let's consider an animation
where I look at lambda k
where k lambda goes
from 0 to infinity.
This is k.
So initially, lambda
k is very, very small.
And I imagine it growing.
It gets bigger and
bigger and bigger.
So it gets bigger and bigger.
And let's think
about the first time
that this growing body
hits a lattice point,
a non-zero lattice point.
At that point, I
freeze the animation.
And I record this vector.
I record this vector where
I've hit a lattice point.
And now I continue
the animation.
It's going to keep on
growing and growing
and growing until when I
hit a vector in a direction
I haven't seen before.
So it's going to keep growing.
And then the next time I hit
a vector in a new direction,
I stop the animation.
And I look at the other vector.
So I keep growing this ball
until I hit new vectors,
keep growing this convex body.
So for example, if your initial
convex body is very elongated,
if that's your k--
so you keep growing, growing--
you might initially
hit that vector.
And then you keep on growing it.
And the next vector
you hit might still
be in the same direction.
But I don't count it.
I don't stop the
animation here, because I
didn't see a new direction yet.
I only stop the animation
when I see a new direction.
So I keep growing until
I see a new direction.
And I stop the animation there.
So think about this growing
body, and stop in every place
when you see a new direction
contained in your lambda k.
And the places where
you stop the animations,
they're the successive
minimum of k.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this defined
if i is greater than d?
YUFEI ZHAO: Is this defined
when i is greater than d?
No.
So you only have exactly
d successive minimum.
Now, sometimes you might
see two new directions
at the same time.
That's OK.
But once you exhaust
all d directions,
then there's no more new
directions you can explore.
We also consider the
vectors that you see.
So let me also call
these so that we can--
OK, so we can select
these lattice vectors bi.
I am going to use
underscore to denote.
So I'm going to use this
underline to denote boldface.
So it's a vector bi, which
is in, basically, this.
You should think of bi as
the new vector that you see.
And it will have the property
such that b1 through bd
form a basis of Rd.
So I keep growing
this convex body.
When I see a vector in a new
direction, I record lambda.
And I record the vector bi.
I keep on going,
keep going, keep
going until I exhaust
all d directions.
I call these b's the
directional basis.
OK.
Any questions?
All right.
So the result from the
geometry of numbers
that we're going to
need is something called
Minkowski's second theorem.
So Minkowski's
second theorem says
that if you have
lambda, a lattice,
in Rd and k, a centrally
symmetric body, also in Rd,
such that lambda
1 through lambda
d are the successive minima
of k with respect to lambda,
then one has the inequality
lambda 1, lambda 2.
So the product of
these successive minima
times the volume of k
is upper bounded by 2
to the d times the
determinant of lambda.
For example, and here is
a very easy case of this
Minkowski's second theorem, if
your k is an axis-aligned box--
namely, it is a box where the
width in the i-th direction is
2 over lambda i--
so then you see that the
successive minima of this box
are exactly the lambda i's.
And you can check that for--
this inequality is
actually an equality.
OK.
So actually, in this
case, lambda, the lattice,
is the integer lattice.
Now, this is a pretty easy case
of Minkowski's second theorem.
But the general case, which
we're not going to prove,
is actually quite subtle.
I mean, the proof
itself is not so long.
It's worth looking up and trying
to see what the proof is about.
But it's actually
rather counterintuitive
to think about.
It's one of those theorems
where you sit down
for half an hour or an hour.
You're trying to prove.
You think you might have
come up with a proof.
And then on closer
examination, it'll
be very likely that you
made some very subtle error.
So it's not so easy to
get all the details right.
And we're going
to skip the proof.
But any questions
about the statement?
OK.
We're going to use
Minkowski's second theorem
to show that a large Bohr
set contains a large GAP.
And specifically, we will
prove that every Bohr
set of dimension d
and width epsilon--
epsilon is between 0 and 1--
in Z mod nZ contains a proper
GAP with dimension at most d
and size at least
this quantity, which
is epsilon divided by d raised
to the power of d fraction
of the cyclic group.
So just to step
back a bit and see
where we're going,
from everything
that we've done earlier, we
conclude that 2A minus 2A
contains a large Bohr set.
Here, epsilon is 1/4.
So epsilon is a constant.
And R is also going
to be a constant.
It's depending on the
doubling constant.
And this proposition
will tell us
that inside this 2A
minus 2A, we will
be able to find a very
large, proper GAP.
So "proper" means that in
this generalized arithmetic
progression, all the
individual terms are distinct,
or you don't have collisions.
So you're going to find
this proper GAP that
is constant dimension
and at least
a constant fraction of the
size of the group, so pretty
large GAP.
To find this GAP, we
will set up a lattice
and apply Minkowski's
second theorem.
Suppose the Bohr
set is given by R
where the individual
elements, I'm
going to denote by little
r1 through little rd.
And let uppercase lambda be
a lattice explicitly given
as follows.
It consists of all points in
Rd that are congruent mod 1
to some integer multiple of the
vector r1 over n, r2 over n,
through rd over n,
so congruent mod 1.
So for example, in two
dimensions, which is all
I can draw on the board,
if r1 and r2 are 1 and 3
and n equals to
5, then basically,
what we're going to have is
a refinement of the integer
lattice, where this box is
going to be the integer lattice.
And I'm going to tell you some
additional lattice vectors.
And here, it's going to repeat,
or it's going to tile all over.
So I start with 1, 3.
And I look at multiples of it.
But I mod 1.
So I would end up with these
points and then repeat it.
And so you would have--
so that's the lattice.
So you have this
lattice, lambda.
What is the volume?
What is the determinant
of this lattice?
So the determinant
of the lattice,
remember, is the volume of its
fundamental parallelepiped.
So I claim that the determinant
is exactly 1 over n.
There are a few
ways to see this.
So one is that, originally,
I had the integer
lattice as determinant 1.
And now I put--
instead of one point,
I have endpoints
in each original parallelepiped.
So the determinant has to
go down by a factor of n.
Or you can construct an explicit
fundamental parallelepiped
like that.
And then you use
base times height.
OK.
We're going to apply
Minkowski's second theorem.
And I will need to tell you--
I don't need the definition
of Bohr set up there.
So I want to tell you what
to use as the convex body.
The convex body that
we're going to use
is k being this box
of width 2 epsilon.
So that's the lattice.
That's the convex body.
And we're going to apply
Minkowski's second theorem.
So let's let little lowercase
lambda 1 through lambda d--
so n is d--
be the successive minima
of k with respect to lambda
and b be the
directional vectors,
the rational basis corresponding
to those successive minima.
I claim that the
L-infinity norm of bj
is at most lambda j
epsilon for each j.
And this is basically
because of the definition.
I mean, if you look at the
definition of successive minima
and directional
basis, this is k.
I grow k, grow it by
a factor of lambda j.
And that's the first
point when I see b sub j.
So every coordinate
of b sub j has
to be at most this
quantity in absolute value.
So now let me denote
uppercase L sub j
to be 1 over lambda
jd rounded up.
And I claim that if little
l is less than big L--
lj, Lj-- then little lj--
OK, so if I dilate the bj
vector by factor little l,
so if I plug it in and just
look at these two inequalities,
I obtain an upper
bound of epsilon
over d on the L-infinity
norm of lj bj,
so just looking at this bound
here and the size of lj.
And if this holds for
all j, then summing up
all of these individual
inequalities,
we find that the sum of
these lj bj's is at most
epsilon in L-infinity norm.
So the point here
is that we want
to find the GAP
in this Bohr set.
And how does one
think of a Bohr set?
So it's kind of hard to
imagine, because the Bohr set
is a subset of Z mod n.
But the right way to
think about a Bohr set
is in a higher dimensional lift,
because a Bohr set is defined
by looking at these numbers
for R different values,
R different coordinates.
So we think of each r
as its own coordinate.
So we think of there
being capital uppercase
R many coordinates.
And we want to
consider the set of x's
so that all the coordinate
values are small.
So instead of considering
a one-dimensional picture,
as we do in the Bohr sets,
we're considering a higher
dimensional or
d-dimensional picture
and then eventually
projecting what happens up
there down to this Bohr set.
So what does Minkowski's
second theorem
have to do with anything?
Well, once you have this higher
dimensional lattice, what we're
going to do is find a large
lattice parallelepiped,
so a large structure inside
this higher dimensional
lattice, and then
project it down
onto one-dimensional Z mod n.
So this is the process of--
so you already see some
aspects of a GAP in here.
So these guys,
they're essentially
the GAP that we're going
to eventually wish to find.
And right now, they live in
this higher dimensional lattice.
But we're going to pull
them down to Z mod n.
All right.
Now, where do these
b's come from?
So each b sub j is congruent to
some x sub j times this vector
mod 1 where x sub
j is an integer
between 0 and uppercase N.
So this inequality
up here, star.
So the i-th
coordinate for star--
"coordinate" meaning this
is an L-infinity bound,
so the i-th coordinate is
upper bounded by epsilon.
But the i-th coordinate
bound implies
that if you look at this sum
over here times Ri divided
by N, this quantity,
whatever it is,
is very close to an
integer for each i.
So the i-th coordinates
implies this inequality,
and it's true for every i.
Thus what we find is
that the GAP, which you
already see in this
formula over here--
so the GAP is given like that.
So this GAP is contained
in the Bohr set.
So we found a large
structure in the lattice.
But the lattice came
from this construction,
which was directly
motivated by the Bohr set.
So we find a large
GAP in the Bohr set.
Well, we haven't shown yet it
is large or that it is proper.
So we need to check
those two things.
To check that this GAP
that we found is large,
we're going to apply
Minkowski's second theorem.
Let's check GAP is large.
So by Minkowski's
second theorem,
we find that the size of the
GAP, which is, by definition,
the product of these
upper case L's--
so if you look at how the
uppercase L's is defined,
you see that this
quantity is at least 1
over the product of the
successive minima times
denominator d to the d.
And now we apply
Minkowski's second.
And we find that this
quantity is at least
the volume of k
divided by 2 to the d
times the determinant of the
lattice times d to the d.
But we saw what is the
determinant of the lattice.
It is 1 over N. You have
d to the d, 2 to the d.
And the volume of k,
well, k is just that box.
So the volume of k is
2 epsilon raised to d.
So putting everything
together, we
find that the size of this
GAP is the claimed quantity.
It's a constant fraction
of the entire group.
The second thing that we
need to check is properness.
So what does it
mean to be proper?
So we just want to
know that you don't
have two different
ways of representing
the same term in the GAP.
So if I have the
following congruence,
so if this combination
of the x's is
congruent to a different
combination of the x's where
these little l's
are between 1 and--
OK, so I want to show-- so
to check that it's proper--
so we're in Z mod n--
we just need to check
that if this holds,
then all the corresponding
little l's must
be the same as their primes.
Well, if it is
true, then setting--
let's go back to the lattice--
setting the vector b to
be a vector originally
that corresponds to the
difference of these two
numbers--
so if we set b to be the
difference of these two
numbers, we find that, first
of all, it lies in Z to the d,
because these two numbers are
congruent to each other mod n.
And furthermore, the L-infinity
norm of b is upper bounded by--
I mean, each one of them
has small l-infinity norm.
And this is some
number that is bounded.
It's less than uppercase L.
So the whole thing, this whole
sum, the L-infinity norm,
cannot be larger than
this quantity over here,
where I essentially use the
triangle inequality to analyze
this b term by term.
All of these numbers
are very small,
because if you look at what we
saw up there, so the size of b,
we see that this whole
thing is at most epsilon.
And epsilon is
strictly less than 1.
So you have some vector b,
which is an integer vector,
such that all of its coordinates
have L-infinity norms strictly
less than 1.
So that means that
b is equal to 0.
So b is the 0 vector.
So b is a zero vector.
Thus this thing
here equals to 0.
So this sum here equals to 0.
And since the bi's
form a basis, we
find that the li's
and l prime i's
are equal to each
other for all i.
And this checks the
properness of this GAP.
Yeah.
So this argument, it's not hard.
But you need to
check the details.
So you need to wrap your
mind around changing
from working in a higher
dimensional lattice setting
to going back down to Z mod n.
And the main takeaway
here is that the right way
to think about a Bohr set
is to not stay in Z mod n
but to think about what
happens in d-dimensional space
where d is the dimension
of the Bohr set.
OK.
So now we have pretty
much all the ingredients
that we need to prove
Freiman's theorem.
And that's what we'll do at
the beginning of next lecture.
We'll conclude the proof
of Freiman's theorem.
And then I'll tell you also
about an important conjecture
in additive combinatorics called
a polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture, which
many people think
is the most important
open conjecture
in additive combinatorics.